- On est là pour aider les gens,
mais en même temps, qui quer no?
- Louis-Philippe Parent est
ambulancier chez Urgences-Santé
depuis 15 ans. Il observe que
collègues se sont détériorées
es années en raison
du manque d'ambulanciers.
Les heures supplémires font mait
partie du quotidien.
LOUIS-PHILIPPE PARENT,
ambulancier, Urgence-Santé
que tu es sur place,tes journéet
en 14-15-16 heures.
- La pén
n'a pourtant rien de nouveau.
Le syndicat des am
la dénonce depuis plusieurs
mois. Mais voilà que
maintenant bien réelles.
CLAUDE LAMARCHE, président,
Syndicat du préhospitalier
qu'on vient de frapper le mur.
Et c'estemier décès
malheureusement.
- Une dame de 91 ans a perdus js
avoir attendu les ambulanciers
durant 7 heures.
STÉPHANE SMITH, porte-parole,
Urgenc- Effectivement, il y a eu
7 heures de délais. Beaucoup
trop d'appels urgents, pas assez
de paramédics. Est-ce que ça été
avoir une enquête de la coroner.
- Dans lsamedi
à dimanche, sur le territoire
d'Urgences-Santé, seulement
déployés sur le terrain,alors q.
Les ambulanciers craignent
d'autres tragédieslement, onleme
le dire, les situations
critiques s'accumulent.
- Sur près de 120 candidatures
reçues pdepuis le début de l'an,
moins d'une quarantaine ont
été retenues. C'est trop peu,
selon le syndicat, qui réclame
de paramédics supplémentaires
pour permettre auxers
de reprendre leur souffle.
- On peut pas gérer
s'il y avait une catastrophe
ur.
- Claude Lamarche appelle tous
ses membpause repas en guise
de moyen de pression.
Urgences-Santé appréhende
les cons- Ça - Ça - Ça - Ça - Çs
probablement plus long sur
les appels qui sont non urgentss
exige que les heures
supplémentaires de ses membres
soient rémunérées à taux double,
une solues pour pallier
la pénurie. Il supplie
le gouvernement de débloquer
les fonds nécessaires avant
prévenir.
Ici Hadi Hassin,
Radio-Canada, Mon